So this is a new recent maths result! We've got
this here, a graph which is a network of points
and lines. So you could think of it like a
network of friends; a network of computers;
London Underground map - these are all the classic
examples of networks, points and lines connecting
together. It's slightly unusual this graph; look, all
the points that you normally get in a graph, I've put
them all in one line. And then you can see all
the connections being made between those points.
And when you do that, you know, these connections
these lines they cross each other, crisscrossing
is everywhere. I wonder if we can uh uncross these?
Uncross them without keeping those points in a
straight line. I don't know. This is a way you could
uncross them; maybe if I took some of these lines,
maybe if I lift them up like that they don't
cross anymore.
- (Brady: Oh that's cheating isn't it?)
And then maybe if I take this page here and lift
this up so they don't cross anymore - and what
we've created is something called a book.
- (Book?)
- What? Do you want me to do it in a Southern accent?
- (No it's alright)
- Book? I don't know how to do it in a Southern accent.
It's a book - I'll do it proper Northern. It's a book
graph. So what we've done it's created a graph
using four pages so that the lines now are
uncrossed; and this is special because this
is the first one of its kind that shows
that this type of graph needs four pages
and it can't be done with fewer pages. I'll put
my book away and tell you a little bit more about
book graphs. So that's the idea, so you're going
to put the points on a line; we're going to
try and draw our graph but we're going to try
and connect the points uh like their pages in a
book. Let's start with a simple example, I'll just
start with- I'll just do a square, four points. So
now let's turn that into a book and that means
I'm going to put the points along the spine of
the book. And it's helpful to number these, let's do
1, 2, 3, 4 yeah. Now let's do 1, 2
3 and 4 all in a line where 1 connects to
2; 2 connects to 3; 3 connects to 4;
4 connects to 1 so it goes back like that.
That would be a one page book because I've just
got this top half here that I'm using. So it's a
one-page book, it does depend on the order of your
vertices here. So if I do a different order you
get a different book. Let's do 1, 3, 4, 2
then what do I need? 1 connects to 2 like
that; 2 connects to 3; 3 connects to
4; 4 connects to 1. so I've created a two
page book. Let's see if we can find something that
needs three pages - we could do something like a
complete graph. A complete graph is when you have
the points and the lines and everything's
connected to everything else. So here is a
classic with five points, and I connect everything
to everything else. So it looks like this. Now let's
say I'm going to try and minimise these crossings;
because that's kind of what I'm trying to do with
this book as well. If you imagine these aren't like
elastic or string I could pull two of these lines
out so I could do something that looks like this
and it will only have one crossing. Now if I want
to draw that as a book this is how you would do it.
This pentagon is a loop so if I just name them
that's 1, 2, 3, 4 and 5. I'm going to
draw out my points: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5. Now
I'm going to do the loop first: so 1 connects to
2, connects to 3, connects to 4, connects to
5, 5 connects to 1. And then anything inside
the loop I'll put on page 1. 2 connects to 4,
2 connects to 5 - and you can see I'm going to
have that crossing there. Maybe I'll save that as
the last thing I do. So I've got 2 connects to
4, 2 connects to 5 like that and anything
like outside the loop I'll do on page 2. So what have
I got? 1 connects to 3 and 1 connects
to 4. And then yes there was one line that I
missed which was 3 connects to 5. Because
I know that's going to cross and so I've got two
pages here looking lovely but yeah I'm gonna have
to use three pages. I'll do it in a different colour,
3 connects to 5. So that would be my third
page. So this graph here needs three pages. If these
didn't cross I would have been able to do that in
two pages. In fact you can make a book of any size;
if you've got a complete graph with n points
the book has n divided by 2 pages - or it's that
number rounded up. So if I wanted to make a book
with 100 pages you just do the complete graph
with 200 points. So you can make a book of
any size you want, there's nothing interesting
about that right so who cares. Like what might be
more interesting though is um what about graphs
that can be untangled, right? Let's just look at
a specific kind of graph that's called a planar
graph when you can untangle it. Here we go. So if
you've got a planar graph, if you can draw a
loop you can do it in two pages. I can do my
five points again but maybe with less lines
so they don't cross over this time? So if I've got
a planar graph which means they don't cross, and
I've got a loop, then I can make it two pages. Same
as before: there's my loop, anything inside is page
1; anything outside is page 2. What about if we
don't have a loop? Right, now there's a couple of
ways you can get around this. If you don't have a
loop you could do- I'm going to call it a phantom
loop. So it could be like this: there's no loops
here, I'll call it 1, 2, 3 and 4. But I
can make a phantom loop if I want to: so I can go
1 connects to 2, 2 connects to 3 and I'm
gonna put an imaginary 3 connects to 4 and
4 connects to 1. Then using that I can do
the same idea. Here's the book, and I can go 1
connects to 2, 2 connects to 3; phantom
3 connects to 4, a phantom 4 connects to
1 if I wanted to. And then what's inside that
loop? 2 connects the 4, so I will draw that
on page 1. I would actually get a one page book
here. So you can turn things that don't have loops
into something that has loops. So really now we're
interested in graphs that don't have crossings,
that don't have loops, and you can't even do
phantom loops. So there are graphs like that
as well. I'll show you an example of what something
like that would look like:
(There it is)
- So we've got
a graph here: it's called the Goldner-Harary graph
and you can see it's got no crossings, and it has
as many edges as you can put in it as well - at
least without creating any extra new crossings.
So we can't even put any phantom lines in this.
And this, if we turned that into our book, is going
to be a three page book. Because we can't quite
use the trick I used before. So the three-page
book would look like this: so there we go we've got
our points in a line. We've tried our best, you know
we've connected it as a two-page book and then
we will have one extra line there that they've
put in and that will have to go on the third
page. So this is an example of a planar graph
- which is a graph that has no crossings in it - that
needs three pages. Are there any graphs that need
four pages? And that was the question. We knew that
there were no planar graphs that needed five pages;
so we knew the answer was going to be 3 as
a maximum or 4 as a maximum. And that was the
conjecture. And that was a conjecture for 30
years until uh 2020. So only recently uh we
got our graph; and that's the graph I showed you at
the beginning so let's just take another look
at it. It's got 275 points, it's got 819 edges. You
connect it up, it needs four pages and every order
as well need four pages - it can't be done better.
So this was- for the first time a planar graph
that needed four pages as a book; if you want to
see the original planar graph, so that it's just
points without any crossings in it. You'll
like this Brady.
- (Yeah I'm dying to see that)
You'd love this. It's this beautiful heart-shaped
graph. It's got- I'll give you options: it's
got 275 vertices, 819 edges, and it was found
by uh you know a combination of computer
search - obviously mathematical methods as well - and
they also used just purely mathematical methods
um to find a whole family of graphs like this
that can only be done in four pages and notbetter.
- (Awesome)
This episode was sponsored by
Jane Street. They're a research driven trading
firm with offices all around the world - here are
some of their locations - and they're looking for
smart, curious, talented people to join them. Could
you be one of them? Check out janestreet.com and
click here where it says Join Jane Street. It's
not just jobs on offer, although there's plenty of
them; they also run various programs, internships,
all sorts of stuff that might be right up your
alley. I visited their offices and it's really
impressive, certainly beyond any place I've ever
worked. There's more on the website, check them
out, and there's a link in the video description.
...my guess would have been, you know, what
is the largest area if you had all these you
know diagonals fitting inside a 1x1
box and I would have guessed regular hexagon.
But it's not. So it's this thing,
so this is not a regular hexagon...